kate is so wonderful to connect with you
because we got some amazing news there's
a Canadian like this is massive that has
kind of sunk in what this all means
right now no not at all I actually found
out little sneaky cover reveal moments
on Tuesday so nearly a week ago and I'm
like still blacked out I don't know
what's happening I'm totally in shock
like and I have this it's like a photo
that was printed on a printer at home
but I still don't have to issue in my
hands oh I think it's like it doesn't
feel real until you can like hold it you
know yeah so you've known since Tuesday
now it's out there everyone is
celebrating this cover how has the
response been I mean it's only since
this morning I think I have like 700
emails I'm home doing media which is so
different than normal and I know in my
little home office here doing zoom calls
and just changing my shirts to update my
looks instead of kind of driving around
all day so it's kind of non-stop but in
such a different way than normal so it
just feels crazy it is crazy and how did
you celebrate when you found out this
was finally happening because you've
been in the magazine eight times already
and here yeah on the cover how did you
celebrate did you even have a chance in
isolation so I yeah I did we had a
little a special reveal where my
boyfriend Kevin and I were meant to do
an interview about couples and
Quarantine so I didn't think anything of
it like great we had a cameraman it was
just one person that came over he was
all masked up and you know felt very
safe so we did just he was filming us
for this interview and Kevin started
asking me some questions and they were
all normal and then yes are you on the
cover of Sports Illustrated and I was
like no like I don't know it hasn't come
out what do you mean and he was like
mmhmm and then he gave me that so oh
pretty cool moment and I got to share it
with him and then you know celebrate and
do a lot of face times and tell my very
intimate close circle because I didn't
want it to get leaked or anything right
we've got to celebrate a little but I
think this week we'll get to do a little
bit more and there you are on the cover
with jasmine and Olivia and you shot
this in Bali in early March before the
pandemic happened what was it like for
you to be with the women and actually it
celebrates diversity and it shows us the
power of women coming together what does
that mean for you and what does that
represent so I've been in this issue for
eight years like you said and I think
it's really been an interesting and
amazing thing to watch I'm so close with
the team members of this friend and I
really love this brand and I'm so happy
to be able to represent them because
throughout the eight years that I've
been there I've really seen different
milestones reached and they break a
barrier every time you know they're
adding all the skin colors all those
body shapes all sizes all ethnicities
like there is so many different forms of
beauty and they embrace all of them and
as someone who's been in the magazine
for a while and kind of seen all these
different changes have been it's been
really amazing seeing the fan response I
think before people just appreciated
seeing beautiful women in pictures and
now it's like every girl growing up
everyone it looks as magazine can relate
to someone in the issue there's some
little bit of them in everyone
there's also mobile search so anyone in
the world can grace these pages so it's
like accessible in a way that I think
right really feel connected and part of
it so I feel as though people get a
little bit more excited because they're
like tied into the whole story of it and
talking about that I'm breaking barriers
last week we saw the first transgender
model in the magazine as well Valentina
was that a pivotal moment you think for
the magazine yeah for sure I think it's
amazing so I've already seen you know
vogue posting the story about it in a
different fashion outlets so you really
see that Sports Illustrated pushes and
breaks these barriers and just believes
in beautiful women or beautiful women
and they can be all sorts of different
shapes and sizes and looks and that
doesn't matter in someone many people
will identify with Valentina and feel so
happy to see her almost pages so it's
just so exciting and amazing that
they're able to do that and then it
really does feel like the fashion
industry just follows right along right
behind
what's your definition of beauty I mean
I do think that beauty comes from being
comfortable in your own skin and being
happy with yourself we were doing an
interview before and I think like even
we're prepping for a shoot they're gonna
be working out and you're stressed and
you're anxious and you just like are
kind of pulling yourself down the whole
time because you don't think you're good
enough or there's like enjoying the ride
and enjoying every minute of it and just
working hard because it feels good and
you like love the sweater you love
seeing the changes in your body when you
know you're working hard you know
there's two different ways to do things
right if you are positive and you're
putting out like I'm gonna work my boss
scuse me to get what I want to get to
and that generally looks beautiful and
you you are known for wellness and
mental health and talking about taking
care of yourself at a time like this
through the pandemic what is your advice
to people who are feeling isolated in
our are feeling a little bit lonely yeah
I do think a lot of people are feeling
lonely and you know everyone's at home
so you are sort of more isolated than
ever but we can also all be isolated
I've had more zoom cocktail hours with
my girlfriends I've almost like spoken
to some friends more often because he
can't even person so we zoom or we get
on a chat I also think that you know
feeding yourself healthy nutritious
foods and being active that doesn't mean
you have to go crazy work out just like
get outside go in a walk get some fresh
air I caught myself staying inside for
like two weeks at a time it was snowing
in Cleveland and we just didn't have
great weather and that really started to
like weigh on me so I think getting
outside and if it's a torrential
downpour just for a walk just for some
air eating something that's actually
like good for your body and helping you
rather than kind of breaking you down
can barely help your mental
chocolate-chocolate good congratulations
to you now that you're on the cover what
do you want next oh my god I feel like I
have to just even like appreciate it
like let this moment soak in it's just
so exciting and it just feels unreal
like you dreamed of this for so long and
I can't
you get to do it now just I can't I'm
like speechless but so excited dreams
can come true you're proof of that thank
you so much congratulations to you thank
you